unsung heroes draft for this Monday
coming out of the four games that work
Chris Sims has the trivia question to
pose to me if I get it right I get the
first pick if I get it wrong
Chris gets it what do you got well
alright here we go you should get this
but we'll see Derrick Henry ran for a
hundred time you say this that jinx is I
know hopefully it makes you want to it
makes you choke it's like it's an easy
completion where you're like oh gosh
he's so wide open I don't know Derrick
Henry ran for 195 yards Saturday through
a three yard touchdown pass to Corey
Davis it was the first passing touchdown
from a running back in a playoff game
since 1987 who was the running back that
threw that pass this isn't easy when it
was Alan Rice to the Minnesota Vikings I
said I told stats I got is this easy I
guess he gets this wrong he's not a
Vikings fan he just he's a bullcrap no
no because it was mentioned like ten
times this weekend that's how I know I
know no no I wouldn't have known the
name good job I heard somebody mention
good job giving them again another one
what color is blue thank you good yeah
all right there's a lot of different
ways we can go here but you know what
we're looking for unsung heroes right
the the guy that isn't going to get the
credit the guy that isn't gonna get the
love the guy that isn't gonna get the
praise and one guy who deserves some
praise and we just showed the highlights
on the TV side and Chris Sims and I were
standing there as he scored the
touchdown the first touchdown of the
game he only had three catches they were
all big catches Kendrick born in the San
Francisco 49ers he scored the first
touchdown he caught that wobbler
remember that wobbler that duck yeah
Jimmy Garoppolo caught up jacked up in
the first half
Kendrick born shot out of a cannon to
catch that one and then in the second
half he had a 20-plus yard gain I think
that was right before the 49ers went in
to run the ball run the ball run the
ball run the ball mode but Kendrick born
three catches all critical catches all
in big spots including the first
touchdown to the game this is a guy that
gets overlooked because the Deebo Samuel
and Emmanuel Sanders but I think he's a
guy that has a lot of promise for the
49ers and and he's not gonna get any
praise or at least not nearly as much as
he should for what he did on Saturday
but we're giving it to him here unsung
hero Kendrick born yeah I mean he's been
in a great addition for that team I mean
it's just another guy that you go okay
we got debo Samuel we got Kittel we got
Emmanuel Sanders covered we're good
right oh wait hold gosh there's another
guy we got to worry about in the past
game been very reliable for Shanahan and
that 49er offense all year you're right
he's made some big catches and made some
big ones on Saturday all right I'm gonna
piss you off here because I'm not going
with one person I'm going with the unit
but this is how the unit goes sorry deal
with it
Titans offense aligned I mean how could
their the unsung heroes of the playoffs
right now I mean what they're doing it's
unbelievable it's three weeks in a row
of just utter domination whether you go
to week 17 and Derek Henry running for
230 yards against the Houston Texans or
what they did the Patriots or what they
did nobody does that to the Baltimore
Ravens nobody they got more big guys and
they're one of the best run stopping
teams in all of football I mean it's
just shocking to be able to move the
Baltimore Ravens that way
Roger Saffold first of all is the guy
that always jumped out to me he's the
best run blocking offensive lineman on
their team at left guard but LaJuan
Conklin Jones I mean they're all doing
great job it's just unbelievable you
know what they're gonna do and you can't
stop it right now and that's what's
scary they deserve a lot of credit the
big ugly's down in Tennessee the Titans
o-line yeah I agree with that completely
but you know I think they're going to be
even more unsung because we just look at
Derek Henry and yeah I know he would be
done what he's doing without the
blocking but offensive line defensive
line those are the keys to getting a
team to the Super Bowl and helping them
win it and they do get not nearly as
much credit as they showed especially
offensive line because in a high profile
game when things go well the Derek
Henry's the quarterbacks the receivers
they're they're the ones who are going
to get the the credit so good one Bayou
my next one is Andy Reed and here's why
here's why I think that that you know
we're look Patrick my home is gonna get
all the praise yeah and in the offense
and then dialing and I'm getting it done
but Andy Reed was just like this calm
presence right he's been through games
like this before he's been on the wrong
side of a game like this before remember
the 38 210 lead that he blew against the
Colts several years back so I mean he
didn't freak out and I think that as the
leader
on the sidelines his attitude his
influence he didn't make some crazy
decision right he didn't try to he
didn't try to gain 24 points back in one
play yeah he just let's just go about
our business and everything will be fine
right and I think his ability his
experience his wisdom his ability to
stay calm and show the confidence in his
guys allowed them to show confidence in
themselves and again it's not gonna show
up anywhere on any statistical breakdown
of the game but I think the presence the
experience the wisdom of Andy Reid
allowed the Chiefs to believe that they
were capable to doing exactly what they
did yeah I agreed Mike I mean just
showed no panic on the sidelines like
you saw yeah okay disappointment and
concern a little but it wasn't like
panic that's that I mean that's Andy
Reid it's unbelievable there and then
you know just trust it in his players he
started calling more aggressive plays
that's to me and you know again one of
those things Kansas City's got to
continue to if teams are gonna play
man-to-man against them they gotta keep
throwing the ball down the field
you got Tyreke and mahomes of that great
arm you know you got a Mobile's gonna
have to scare people off that way and
they did that because either they made
big plays or they got a pass
interference call too that's the other
thing that happens but yeah love and
Andy Reid loving it and I'm just saying
right now I'm rooting for Andy Reid to
win the AFC Championship now I'm out
there I'm putting it putting it out
there all right
good for him to win the Super Bowl know
it depends who gets there that's so
tough one yeah if it's the 49ers in the
Chiefs if it's the 49ers the Chiefs re
it'd be like that would be I can't root
for him and that would be horrible if
yeah I couldn't I couldn't but you know
I understand you got a lord a good
tattoo buddy no doubt about it so my
second pick though I'm going to the the
Smiths okay in Green Bay because once
again they proved to be a huge part of
what the Green Bay Packers do I don't
know maybe I should give it to Gooden
coos the GM of the Packers I don't know
but I'm gonna go the Smith Brothers
you're gonna do to me up good acuity
canoes and Coons whatever I can't say
goudi that's what I call him I just got
to stick with that but the Smith
Brothers brothers from another mother I
mean they were unbelievable again just
the ability to you know collapse the
pocket be around Russell Wilson then
yeah did Russell Wilson make a number of
scrambles
things like that yes sure I mean that's
Russell Wilson he's unstoppable at times
but these two guys not only were they
big time on Sunday night they changed
around this organization I think you
could argue that they had more impact on
a football team than any other two free
agent signed by a team and all the NFL
last year they have been phenomenal
they've given this team an attitude a
toughness and the ability to rush the
quarterback with four they don't need to
blitz and we talked about that all time
so great job by them yeah and look I I
don't want to push back on you too hard
on this one and I I don't like it when
there's only four games forced to choose
from because we're gonna have duplicates
and of course the unsung heroes are
gonna come from the winning teams yeah I
think that za'darius Smith and Preston
Smith get plenty of craze plenty of
praise plenty of credit we hear about
him all the time
I think the unsung hero for the Packers
defense was JR Alexander for one moment
okay I like that the owner the corner
blitz on the two-point conversion right
because there's a huge difference
psychologically for the two teams in the
fourth quarter if it's twenty eight
twenty three and if its twenty eight
twenty five and and you know field goal
versus touchdown that changes everything
and you have to you have to go back to
that point and replay the rest of the
game to see how it plays out in the
minds of both teams but you're a little
bit tighter if you're the Packers and
you're only up three and you're a little
bit you know and it just changes the
dynamic entirely and I think it helps
the Packers to have had that five point
lead instead of the three point lead and
you know I ain't maybe if it was only a
three point deficit I don't know maybe
maybe Pete Carroll would have gone for
it on fourth and 11 thinking if we hold
him to a field goal touchdown still wins
the game but either way there was a huge
play and it was just like a momentum
swing not a huge one right but but at a
time when everything's going Seattle's
way to just kick it back a little bit
and keep me from getting the two-point
conversion I think gave the Packers a
nice little boost going in the last few
minutes of the game yeah I think there's
something to know that the other team
has to score a touchdown to beat you
does change the game it changes the
dynamic of everything you're right and
you know again not that I know this for
sure but I didn't feel like Jaya Jaya
Alexander and the way the Green Bay
plays defense they asked their guys to
play man-to-man he didn't seem to be the
guy getting beat last night
you know more times than not
and I know he was in some tough
situations playing DK Metcalf and some
of those other guys but I don't know I
got to go back and watch the film but to
me when they lock it made a lot of the
big throws I don't remember
Jair Alexander being the culprit of bad
coverage there - he's been great for
them
hey there was a month there was a moment
where he and DK Metcalfe kind of got
face to face a little bit and it's
impossible to get face to face because
there's probably that much yeah right -
and he Alexander does not back down and
look regardless of who's responsible for
it
Metcalfe wasn't anywhere close to the
production that we saw earlier against
the no definitely not and I would bet
you it is because of the guy you just
drafted he is an unsung hero so I hear
you there all the way all right I'm
gonna go you know Travis Kelce I'm gonna
go with Travis Kelce because again I
know he had good stats and things like
that we're gonna talk about my homes and
the place he made Andy read all that but
I just like Travis Kelce dropped that
gets to drop early you know could have
easily gotten the tank but to me this is
where he really becomes unsung we saw
some of those plays first off some of
those plays not only great route running
but a few of these plays he's
double-teamed he's not open some of the
touchdown catches I mean this is a
phenomenal catch you know that's a
rocket Lowe in a way that he just snags
with his hand here the Texans got him
covered
he just got great feel and that's why I
give them the unsung hero a lot of these
catches are just him and mahomes playing
backyard football like hey dude you know
I'm over here and mahomes knowing where
he's gonna move and just unable and his
ability to uncover when covered and to
do those type of things and just run
routes like a wide receiver he just adds
such another element to their offense
and you know that's the discouraging
thing with the with the Kansas City
Chiefs you could call them the best
defense in the world to have everybody
covered
mahomes breaks the pocket those guys
know how to react off of them and it's a
30 yard gain and you go down what do we
do what do you how do you stop this crew
and kelsey has just got phenomenal feel
as well as being a phenomenal player in
the pass game I still have a hard time I
know you do you're very touched
show he is sung he's very well sung
where it's and we haven't talked about
him that's unsung territory okay yeah
one of the guy that I had on my list was
Arthur Arthur Smith the Titans yeah
kinds of coordinator and you know
between him and Kevin savants Kihei
Browns and it's funny because Jimmy
Haslam is a Tennessee guy Arthur Smith
is the son of FedEx CEO Fred Smith in an
industry rife with nepotism and doing
favors for buddies and and Fred Smith
was on the pilot Flying J board of
directors when when Jimmy Haslam onda
it's astounding to me that Arthur Smith
hat wasn't even considered maybe he'll
be the next coach after Kevin Stefanski
ends up flaming out maybe at some point
the son of the FedEx CEO will end up you
know a little a little Tennessee
connection there we're gonna take a
break and when we return they are
calling for the head of Bill O'Brien in
Houston should he stay should he go
we'll discuss when pfg life continues
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports